- You always have great hair.
Has it--
- Do I?
- Yes, in every character,
like in person right now,
I'm like, you can just like,
it feels like you just
ran your hands through it
and then just came out here.
- I did.
- Looking like a stud.
Yeah!
(laughing)
Is it, have you always had
great hair since you were a kid?
- No.
- No?
- I had a mother who thought it was
a really good idea for me to just sport
a bowl cut pretty much
through my entire adolescence
and into--
- Oh my God!
This is a picture of me too.
That's what I looked like.
- That's, we're twins.
- Yeah.
- That's sort of, but that was like young.
You can really understand it at that age,
but it carried on into like middle school
and into, I mean, I feel in a way,
Like I was kind of born
to play Spock because like
when I was in puberty, I had
like a full blunt bang cut.
Like it was a, not great.
- Oh my God!
Or it built, it was character building.
- It was character,
literally character build--
I had to arrive at a
place where I was like,
in the mirror, like maybe
the hair should be off my face, you know?
And that was a,
that was a real significant moment
in my personal evolution I would say.
- It should be off your face.
'Cause you also, this is no joke,
and they didn't even know that I was going
to say this, you have my favorite
eyebrows on any man ever.
- Oh my gosh!
- Like you have the greatest eye--
You're like the Brooke Shields of men.
(laughing)
Like, it's like,
you know what I'm saying?
It's like, you have the greatest,
I have to draw these on.
Like these are drawn, like.
- I do too.
- Shut up.